هي المدينه او المحور الاكثر سخونه
والاكثر اهميه بكل المحاور حيث التطورات
الاخيره
فاجنر على لساني بريغوجن قائد المجموعه
يؤكد بان القوات الخاصه الروسيه تتقدم في
المحور الغربي وتسيطر كل يوم على جزء من
المناطق الغربيه الحديث عن 400 متر تقدم
في العمق الغربي يوم امس وان المتبقي اقل
من كيلو متر واحد كان هناك سيطره على
باديوم وعلى منطقه تدعى سمالوط الطائره
وان شارع
تتقدم فيه قوات فاجنر بطريقه طوليه من اجل
الوصول الى اخر المدينه
لكنه اشار في ذات الوقت محمد بان من
المبكر الاعلان او الحديث عن اعلان سيطره
قوات فاجنر على المدينه ذلك بعد انسحاب
الجيش الروسي من المحور الذي كان مركز فيه
من الناحيه الجنوبيه قوات فاجنر ارسلت
قوات تعزيزيه لتلك المنطقه لان الجيش
الاوكراني بالفعل بعد يعني تمركز في
المنطقه الغربيه بدا يتمدد من الناحيه
الغربيه الجنوبيه والغربيه الشماليه وهذا
ما يهدد او ينذر
بتطويق لقوات فاغنر داخل المدينه حتى لو
وصلوا الى العمق الغربي فهذا يعني انهم
سيصبحون محاصرين محاصرون من الناحيه
الغربيه والشماليه والجنوبيه ومع وصول
الاسلحه المتطوره لعيد المقاتلين
الاوكرانيين سيصبح الجيش الروسي او قوات
فاجنر المتمركزه او المسيطره على كامل
اجزاء المدينه من الداخل في مرمى نيران
القوات الاوكرانيه لذلك يقول بريغوجين
بانه من المبكر الحديث عن انتصار ويجب
تعزيز الجبهات الجنوبيه والشماليه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات